okay so I just got back from a midnight
screening of prometheus I don't usually
do midnight screenings but my schedules
been pretty hectic this is the only time
I could work it in uh so yeah I'm
literally just gonna talk about it right
after I saw it so my memory may not be
best but I'll do my best to talk about
it give you a review of it um first of
all I should say that I was one of the
people that was not super hyped for this
movie not that I didn't want to see it
but I didn't get why so many people were
so excited I mean people were really
really hyped for this and I didn't quite
get it uh because I thought the Alien
franchise was pretty old um you know it
was good but I I mean like Avengers or
Batman I could see I didn't get this the
only thing I could figure is that I
guess people were excited to see Ridley
Scott back in the director's chair they
were excited to see something news or
done with it's not just straight-up
scares and they were excited to get
answers uh you know that were raised
from the very froze alien movie let's be
honest the alien movies never really
answered where these things came from or
what that ship was and so forth so I
think people were excited about that I
bring this up because it's if you're one
of those people that was really high for
those reasons um chances are you're
gonna kind of be disappointed this is
sort of the I don't like using this
comparison but it's only one I can
really think of this is sort of like the
lost of the Alien franchise in that it's
pretty much promising you these answers
and it's really building it up and it's
promising you that the answers they're
going to give you are really smart and
really good and going to deliver and
they only answer a handful of things and
what they do deliver on is only so-so
okay it's sort of very basic and very
vague and the other stuff that they
don't answer they're most likely
building up for a sequel and that is
very
frustrating I think that says someone
who is not hyped the movie when it began
got me height it sucked me into this
world and that is what's good about the
movie is that it does love the world
it's in and you love being in this world
and you love the designs and you love
how huge everything is and you love the
technology and you love seeing people do
the stuff with the technology it sort of
like a Miyazaki film you love seeing
people work with this stuff um but
outside of that there's there's a few
good things as some of the characters
are memorable and you do like them but
many of them are just there to die it
goes back to a lot of same horror
mistakes that people make in you know
sci-fi / horror films um aside the quick
without giving away two main spoilers
the the summary of the film is that
there's apparently these from every
primitive dialect or whatever age and
civilization there's these um drawings
there's these images they keep
reappearing and they think it came from
a source from far far away the great
beyond
well this ship has finally discovered it
and they can travel to it of course
nobody else knows about because it's
top-secret blah blah blah
uh so they bring along you know the
scientists and a little bit of military
and and so forth to go and see what's
out there and they come across basically
this I don't think I'm giving anything
away by saying it's a ship um they come
across this ship this er looks like this
alien craft and they're just looking
around the ship seeing what's on there
and that's the basic summary uh again
without giving away too much so
comparing this with like the other
aliens and just alien and aliens that's
the only thing I'm gonna compare it to
it cuz nobody cares about the air films
um it does feel like an alien movie it
starts off very much like an alien movie
uh in that there's a lot of atmosphere
to it and
you know the Android is great very
memorable and you know the captain is
pretty memorable everyone else sir falls
into that Jurassic Park sort of category
where it's like oh that's the funny one
oh that's the nerd oh that's the bully
oh that's the romantic couple that says
there guy be together forever guess what
happens to one or both of them uh and on
the one hand it's kind of nice to see
because you're just are having fun oh
this really feels like an alien movie
because of that on the other hand it
gets a little frustrating because when
they do just deliver with exactly what
you know you're gonna get you just get
exactly what you know you're gonna get
but the the joy of this film like as it
is the world is the technology but I
don't think it comes through enough that
fans are really going to enjoy it unless
you're excited to see more sequels if
you're like oh I want to see more I want
to see more of this story and these
characters and stuff maybe you'll enjoy
it but these characters are not that new
and one of the strongest points to the
alien movies I'd argue even sort of the
bad ones is you really remember the
characters you really remember these via
they're not just people who are going to
die you really remember these people and
you don't want to see them die so many
of these characters I think I can
remember you know three or four you know
that that I liked and I wanted to see
keep going um you know and that's not
the case with the other alien movies
like I said even sir the bad ones uh you
know I remember Ron Perlman around the
guy in the wheelchair I'm not the guy
with the cool voice I'm from alien four
you know and that's a horrible movie uh
but I still sort of remember those guys
um you know the guy was a great shot in
blah blah blah uh this one I can count
them on my hand who I remember uh
everyone else is just there to die and
that's a disappointment uh should talk a
little bit about Charlize Theron
this I think not only is she kind of
missed cash she's supposed to be really
tough and really the you know we're
gonna do things my way and I
you need like a Linda Hamilton or an
Emma Thompson or is that someone I can
really command authority and she's not
horrible I don't think she has that um
there's a little bit of a twist in there
with the guy who started this whole
operation and stuff it's not a very good
strong twist um
and everything that pretty much it's
been building up to just comes down to
the most basic it's such a basic it's so
disgustingly simple um but in the end
it's like why is it so disgustingly
simple let's venture forth and find out
in Prometheus 2 and Oh for me it was
very frustrating and I was someone who
was not hyped so my guess would be that
if you are very hyped to see this movie
and hype to get some answers well that's
the key words some answers you'll get a
few answers everything else is build-up
for another one it's not like you can
just go from this into alien that's not
how it works it's that you have to go
from this and maybe a couple other films
however many they want and then we'll go
into alien my guess is that's gonna piss
off a lot of people but maybe you'll be
ok I think the people who probably would
like this are people who like getting
sucked into this world it is a very
engaging fun world um you know and they
like the environment people who don't
mind sir those Jurassic Park stereotyped
characters because they are here and
they're not too annoying some are but it
it plays it ok and throughout the
majority of the film you're invested you
do want to know what's going on and you
are sort of sucked into this mystery and
who's a good guy who's a bad guy so that
is fun but the payoff in the delivery
it's just not that interesting and they
are really building up that they're
going to
give you a good payoff and they don't um
like I said it's the most sort of
promoting sci-fi it bad guy gonna
destroy everything it it's really a
disappointment on that front um and you
really want them to give you something
but I bottom like it's very very big on
the answers when they do give answers so
I I guess that's the best I can really
sum up here I haven't dumped a midnight
showing so it's like I haven't had time
to really collect my thoughts too much
but am I glad I saw it yeah because I do
like this world uh and I do sort of like
the pacing it's a good pacing um but I
think for what for what the movie is
promising just from the beginning of the
film I'm not talking about trailers just
from the beginning of the film what the
film is promising it doesn't really
deliver and maybe years from now they'll
play the sequels and will say oh that's
what that was and now this makes sense
but even that's the case a lot of these
characters are not very memorable um a
few are but like I said for an alien
film directed by Ridley Scott these are
very forgettable people you can't grab
on to a lot of them you can't sympathize
with a lot of them you can't even get
into their motivations half the time so
I think that is a major problem but like
I said I'm glad I saw because I enjoy
the mystery and I enjoy the world that
they created um anyone else looking for
like as it answers you're probably going
to be disappointed that's about the best
I can deliver there any I didn't hate
the film I had some good stuff I think
people are probably gonna be let down a
little bit by it or maybe not if you go
see it and you're okay with not getting
all the answers maybe you enjoy this
okay cuz it does have that alien feel
and I think people will like to sort of
see that again
but ya doing you've heard my two cents
I'm just gonna be repeating myself by
now so uh go check it out for yourself
or if you sound like you won't enjoy it
you might want to give it a skip so
that's about it and talk to you later